A significant hurdle when authoring UI with a code backend is that I'm grabbing parts
of the visuals that don't yet exist. For instance, how can we update a text field
in code when the field itself was added later in Blueprint, because we won't have
a reference to it? Luckily, Unreal presents two exceptionally
important new property specifiers to empower the UI programmer, that being the bind widget
and the bind widget anim. Let's take a look at how we'd go about
using them, and what functions we'd bring in around them to develop more smarter pieces
of UI. Bind widget is a meta specifier intended for
use with widget pointers in our user widget classes, and allows a designer to populate
native C++ level members with a designer created widget. This does kind of fly in the
face of the general Unreal development pipeline that have a blueprint layer sitting on top
of a C++ one. In this case, we're essentially leaving a gap in the C++ layer for a blueprint
layer to fill it in for us. Let's talk through a practical example.
Let's say we've got a C++ class based off of user widget with a uTextBlock member.
The uTextBlock container is exactly what you'd think it is, it's a widget capable
of rendering text in UMG. If we flag this up with the bind widget
specifier, we're saying to the compiler that this particular widget is populated
from the designer layer. We don't need to initialise it in the native code like
we would with an actor component. This frees up any UI designers to implement the text
block for us and change its visuals, its positions, its parenting, and any other parameters
that they may need to adjust as per the design. As engineers, we're now free to assume
that this field is now valid and can carry on developing as we would otherwise.
But of course, it is a pointer, so validity checks are still always a pretty smart idea.
But you may be asking yourself, why can we assume it's valid? Well, the blueprint
will fail to compile if it's not compliant with the underlying native code.
Bind widget is signaling to the blueprint layer, hey, I need a widget of this type
with this specific name to properly work, so you need to add one.
Failure to comply will manifest much like any other blueprint compilation failure.
A warning error will be thrown up as soon as we try and play the game in the editor,
and a whole host of errors will be thrown into the log, so it's not a good time.
It's worth noting that the bind widget will happily bind to an existing widget as
long as it matches in name and in type. The compiler isn't looking for the creation
of such a widget, it's merely looking for the existence of one. Once we compile with
a compliant widget in the designer, the blueprint compiler is going to populate the underlying
C++ with the designer version of the widget, filling any gaps we may have deliberately left.
At this point, we've not actually got any widgets in the viewport, we're still
just looking at the designer. Why would we need any widgets to be passed
down into the native code when we're not actually running the game?
This is where our smart UI elements come into play.
SynchronizeProperties is a virtual function that we can override to develop smart, responsive
UI tools. In many ways, it mirrors the on-construction or post-edit property virtuals we typically
use when authoring smart actor classes. It will be called every time a property changes
within a specified widget in both the designer and at runtime.
Because it's called both at runtime and in the designer, we more often than not want
to branch the logic inside depending on the current environment.
Wrapping logic in a isDesignTime check means we can quite easily run design-only
So let's take a look at a practical example of how we'd use BindWidget in combination
with SynchronizeProperties to empower the UI designers as well as ourselves to build
more complex pieces of UI. In this example, we're implementing the
SynchronizeProperties function and supering it back up the chain so there's nothing special there.
We're then checking to see if we're in the designer, and if so, we check to see
if the container widget is valid. containerWidget in this instance is a BindWidget property.
If we've yet to create a valid widget in the designer for this property to bind to,
when we compile we're going to hit a null pointer.
If it does exist, however, we're going to remove all the children that are inside so
we've got a fresh container to work with before proceeding through our dynamic spawn
of as many children as the child number is set to.
Of course this is a very simplistic example but even here we can see the implications
of real authoring. The alternative would be a designer manually
creating a vertical box and dragging in as many images as they want directly.
Why have the specifications changed and we need to increase the number of images?
Suddenly we're dealing with a less than trivial UI rework.
With smart and sensible use of SynchronizeProperties, we can author responsive pieces
of UI that empower the team as opposed to laboring them with more work than is
strictly necessary. bindWidgetAnim allows us to grab named
animations from the designer much in the same way that we grab widgets when using the bind widget.
When defining animations in native C++, we simply create a member of type UWidgetAnimation
and use the name of the animation to create the underlying binding.
When we want the animation to play, it's as simple as calling the playAnimation from within
our user widget, passing along the bound animation. Much like bindWidget, a failure to
bind to an animation of a particular name will also cause a compilation failure.
We'll also fail to compile if the widget animation isn't marked with the transient
specifier along with the bindWidgetAnim meta. This is primarily due to how widgets
themselves play animations under the hood. During the compilation, the animations themselves
get copied out of the user widget into a holding container as part of the transient package.
Marking the animations as transient prevents these copied versions from being serialized.